this morning a young kentucky man says
his life is on hold because a heart
condition
left him with massive debt despite
having health insurance
we're looking at his case in our
continuing bill of the month partnership
with kai kaiser health news and npr
examining unexpected medical costs the
now 31 year old is dealing with big
bills
and bankruptcy just to be able to live a
normal life after
years of medical care i just stopped
going to the movies i stopped going to
basketball games
matthew fentress was just 25 years old
when he was diagnosed with
cardiomyopathy
a condition that makes it harder for the
heart to pump blood
throughout the body three years ago
doctors inserted a pacemaker and
defibrillator
in fentress to save his life fentress
had
insurance but when he couldn't afford
his five thousand dollar hospital bill
he declared bankruptcy then this january
his cardiologist suggested fentress
undergo a cardiac ablation procedure
to restore normal heart rhythm and offer
him a better quality of life
it's not really living if all i do is
sit around the house
and not be able to enjoy anything i used
to do
the bill for that better life 258
thousand dollars his insurance
negotiated the bill down
and paid more than 26 thousand dollars
but due to his high deductible plan
fentress was on the hook for close to
eight
thousand dollars and you get so many
bills
that it's almost like they pile up on
you
fentress has yet to pay any of the bill
and is filing paperwork to negotiate the
amount with his hospital
but until then he says his life is on
hold can't get a credit card i can't
buy a house i don't see me ever being
out of debt
united healthcare says it's worked with
baptist health louisville
for many years to help reduce health
care costs
it says matthew fentress's procedure was
covered correctly under his plan
which has a maximum out of pocket limit
of seventy nine hundred dollars a year
baptist health louisville says it gave
fentress an estimate of seventy eight
hundred and eighty eight dollars
before the procedure it also says he has
not applied for financial assistance but
is likely eligible
and they're prepared to expedite the
process we're joined now by dr elizabeth
rosenthal editor-in-chief at kaiser
health news
elizabeth good morning thanks for being
with us whenever i watch one of these
stories
i just remember how how you open those
envelopes those bills with such
trepidation
because you don't know what you're going
to see inside but matthew had
insurance so how did he get stuck with
such a large bill
yeah this guy is someone who did
everything right you know you're told to
buy
insurance you don't have a lot of money
so you look at the premium and buy the
cheapest plan or the plan you can afford
the most you can afford
and we're primed to look at the premiums
right
and we're now kind of primed to look at
deductibles as well
but what really hit matthew was not just
the deductibles
but also there's something that's kind
of a nouveau charge called the
co-insurance
so 20 of everything on his hospital bill
he was expected to pay too and that's
what put him over the edge
yeah what is that exactly elizabeth
well it is exactly what it sounds like
everything you're charged for in the
hospital
the patient is expected and some kind of
lower level
cheaper plans to pay 20 percent of and
as we know
you know the the rack rate for that
procedure was
over two hundred thousand dollars
luckily what insurance
does still do is you get the insurance
negotiated rate so it was 2700
but still if you look at all those
different bills it really adds up
and there is an out-of-pocket yearly
maximum in his case it was
i think 8 900 but the thing is
that resets january first so
you know if your procedure and your
complications span two years
you're going to have to pay it twice a
lot of unfairness
yeah and you're lucky if you don't get a
heart attack just from the 250 000
initial bill should people avoid high
deductible plans elizabeth
and if they can't what should they know
about that type of plan
well i you you often can't i mean it's
often what you can afford
so i think we have to be primed as
buyers as smart
shoppers which i hate using that term
for patients but
to look not just at the premiums but at
the
deductibles and at the the co-insurance
payments because that's what really got
this young man into trouble
and ps remember he had something that is
a known
complex he actually got it from the flu
but what he had this myocardial problem
is a problem with kovid too it's it's an
important complication of covid
the heart muscle recovers but the
rhythms are often very abnormal
so he desperately needed this procedure
all right dr elizabeth
rosenthal thank you so much